texas has
is really on a roll uh first they passed
the bill
banning abortions after six weeks
and uh they're not slowing down this is
a good lesson what the republicans in
texas are doing
is now and has been for a while a good
lesson for conservatives and other
republicans all across the country you
stay on offense
you know i i think for for many other
republicans well they would never pass
that abortion bill in the first place
but if they did they would spend the
next six years
defending it and that's all they would
do
um
but
texas republicans they've said oh we've
done that that's done
and uh and okay now we're going to do
this and they've now passed a bill
that would ban biological males from uh
female sports
it also by the way bans females from bio
from from male sports but that never
really comes up because you never you
know you very rarely see it in the
reverse where the females which which is
a very which is a very interesting
phenomenon even though transgenderism is
far more common
um among adolescent girls
the sports issue is almost exclusively
boys trying to play against the girls
wonder why that is
so the legislator passed this build it
is now on on greg governor abbott's desk
where i assume he will be signing it
today or or soon at least
and the media is responding as you can
expect and so is the white house this is
from axios says a white house
spokesperson on tuesday condemned a
texas bill that would force public
school students to play on sports teams
based on their assigned sex at birth
forced them for it would force them to
do exactly what everyone in sports has
been doing
from time immemorial
it would it would force them to do
exactly what we've all been doing
which is that you play against members
of your same sex
um
it's uh let's see here this this is
according to a white house spokesman
says this hateful bill in texas is just
the latest example of republican state
lawmakers using legislation to target
transgender kids whom the president
believes are some of the bravest
americans
in order to score political points
these anti-transgender bills are nothing
more than bullying disguised as
legislation and they undermine our
nation's core values
which values are those exactly that are
being undermined
by affirming the differences between the
sexes
and affirming that a boy who says he's a
girl
is still is still a male
what value is being undermined exactly
can you go into more detail about that
and as far as targeting transgender kids
the word transgender
isn't mentioned in the legislation
it isn't mentioned in any of these
pieces of legislation that we've seen
around the country
that's it there is no bill anywhere
saying that transgender kids aren't
allowed to play sports
and i tell you right now
whatever you think of me when it comes
to trans issues if if there were if if
there was a legislature
trying to pass a bill saying that uh
quote unquote transgender kids aren't
allowed to play sports i'd be against
that
because the point is precisely that it
it doesn't when you're playing sports it
doesn't matter how you internally
identify or how you perceive yourself
what matters is what biological category
you fall into that's it
as long as you're playing in your own
biological category i don't care how you
perceive yourself doesn't make a
difference
but the media of course going into
overtime
over this and we'll just play one
example here this is a local
news affiliate
in texas
trying to trying to show us the the pain
and suffering and damage that this bill
is going to cause let's watch this
governor greg abbott is expected to sign
this bill which requires athletes to
play on teams that align with their
genders listed on their birth
certificates proponents of the bill say
it will protect girls from having to
compete with stronger and bigger
athletes but trans athletes say it
unfairly targets them abc 13's puja
lodia has a story from an eight-year-old
in her fight for acceptance
sonny bryant and her mother becca have
testified in front of legislators in
austin multiple times they say they want
to share their story because they feel
like people will better understand their
position if they get to know them here
is my
hilarious comic sonny bryant is eight
now but she says she's known who she is
since she was four i am a girl
this is not pretend this is not a phase
um and it's real
it's there's a difference between saying
i want to be a girl and i am a girl
and that was really what they were clear
by her
her family has been supportive and most
of her young classmates don't ask much
they've always played sports like
baseball and gymnastics because they'll
be expelled if they ask any legislature
began debating a bill that would make it
so that she will only be able to play on
boys sports teams she and her mom went
to austin it was kind of emotional
and
no i was kind of the mom went to austin
and dragged him along search of a
problem we haven't had any lawsuits in
the state of texas we haven't had any
cases and the population of trans kids
kids is so small so that means she'd be
the only girl in a locker room only girl
on the team she won't have that
community that you get i like baseball
tennis
gymnastics
and soccer what is in my heart is i
think i should be able to play sports
because i am a girl too
sunny is still only eight years old okay
so her mother says she still has it uh
so so we're supposed to believe this
this kind of thing it enrage
it arranges me every time i see it it
will never not enrage me
to see kids being treated this way
by that
i have to stifle myself
i you know i know i just said but we
can't be we can't worry about people's
feelings of being gentle and everything
but um i also don't necessarily
want to get completely deplatformed um
that mother here's what i'll say about
the mother
there is no eight-year-old
on the planet
who is saying to
their mother
let's go to state capitol and lobby over
this bill that's being proposed
hey mom i want to become a political
activist
that's what i want to do
i have eight-year-olds i have two of
them right now
they have no idea what bills are being
passed
the state legislature let's go to the
state capitol and lobby over bills
they're not thinking about that
you know what my son is thinking about
he's thinking about uh he wants to go
outside and and run around and wrestle
around with his brother
and uh and throw rocks at various
objects
they could they could go outside and uh
and that's that's an afternoon i mean
just picking up rocks and like throwing
them at trees
i've told them don't throw them at
anything that's alive but other than
that
throw all you want
that's what they're thinking about
no eight-year-old so we're supposed to
believe that this eight-year-old
has chosen to become a a political
you know advocate
has chosen to be the face of transgender
rights in texas
just like we're supposed to believe that
at four-year-old at four years old this
boy
discovered his inner female identity
and that that mother says well there's a
difference between saying i want to be a
girl and i am a girl yeah really what's
the difference exactly what is the
difference
when a four-year-old says it
is there a difference when a
four-year-old says um
i am a lion versus i want to be a lion
yeah there's no response we we
this of course is the point that we on
the sane side have been making one of
the points
which is that little kids
have no concept of their own identity
they have extremely active imaginations
they get into phases that can last
sometimes for
months or years even
and sometimes kind of weird phases where
they get really obsessed with a certain
idea or concept or or imaginary thing
that's all perfectly normal for kids
which is why a young child can claim to
be an animal or a superhero
or some sort of mythological being
and really believe it on some level
because for
to them the distinction between playing
pretend
between using your imagination
and reality you know there is really no
distinction
that's why at four years four years old
uh you could have a kid who who
almost every parent on the planet at one
point has had a conversation with their
child
about how there's no monsters in the
closet here i'll open up the closet for
you shine a light into it there's no
monsters you see there's nothing in
there
but they don't understand that because
in their heads they feel like there's
monsters in the closet
and so the idea that they could feel
that something is true and yet it not
actually be true
that's not something that they can wrap
their heads around yet
so we keep making this point and the
other side all they do is scoff at it oh
this is totally different a
four-year-old saying they're a
four-year-old boy saying he's a girl
he's not the same as a four-year-old boy
saying he's a dog really it isn't how's
it any different tell me
if the if we on the sane side if we ran
society you know if we had not ceded and
surrendered our society the way that we
have uh that mother will be going to
prison for the rest of her life which is
where she belongs
this is her this as i always say this is
munchausen by proxy this is her imposing
her delusions her sickness her mental
illness onto that child
and then and then tracing him around
like a like a trophy
like a little mascot like a
a prize that she's been awarded
you know we hear about men that have
trophy wives well there are parents that
make little trophy children for
themselves
so they can earn woke points and they
can earn social credibility they can up
their social score
and so they could show the entire world
look at my trans child
i have no sympathy for these parents at
all
i know some people do they say well look
at these parents you know they
they're in a difficult situation they
don't know what to do no no sympathy
look if if you're a parent and you're
adult and and you're a good parent and
you've raised your kids the right way
and your 14 year old girl goes to public
school and comes home one day out of the
blue and says i think i'm a boy
i have sympathy for you there in that
case with with adolescent girls
or boys
who um just one day out of nowhere get
this idea in their head
and uh and you've got the school system
working against you all of their peers
everything in the culture and media i
mean that's one thing but if you're a
four-year-old
you know if you're a parent with a
four-year-old quote transgender
that's on you
and that is really easy that's that's a
really easy problem to solve
very easy
the only way that problem maintains is
if you want it to be that way
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated